this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the Weaponry
from the Grim dark future of the 41st
Millennium in Warhammer 40K dark tide
this is a real closest where we've got
so far to a Balter in terms of this idea
of Rocket ammunition fascinating area of
Technology this is a sort of Highly
stylized idealized version of it make
sure to subscribe and check out our
previous episode of the weapons of
Warhammer 40K when Jonathan took a look
at the guns from necromunda and if you
like this kind of content we've got a
brand new season of Loadout airing on
the channel right now new episodes will
launch every Sunday and you can already
check out our previous episode on the
scar right let's take a look at the
weapons of dark tide
First Impressions very good this looks
like a functional believable firearm
albeit a bit chunky and bulky for what
it's firing which appears to be
conventional brass case Centerfire
ammunition otherwise we've got proper
controls we've got a left-hand charging
handle a proper magazine catch game like
this would typically just have the
player Rip the magazine out of the gun
magically and shove in another one but
this has a has a thumb catch on the left
side for you to operate now the aiming
of this does not let you use the sights
by the look of it this is much more like
an old-school FPS rifle where it just
maybe zooms your view in a bit and
reduces your dispersion but you're not
aiming you're not adsing design Wise
It's you know hard to deny that it
doesn't resemble an AK or maybe more
like a Sega sporting rifle with that
left hand charging handle or psycho
shotgun even with the how pocket the
magazine is but it's spitting out sort
of elongated 556 adjacent cartridge
cases and again I'm not sure why in the
future you would you would want a longer
case I would expect if we're still using
for some bizarre reason conventional
ammunition that the propellant would be
Uber efficient and the cartridges could
be really really small
uh I would probably call this a machine
pistol rather than a submachine gun not
just because it's compact but because it
does not have a shoulder stock or indeed
I think provision for it the design of
this thing really does look suitably
Warhammer what I'm what I'm noticing
here is
um obviously the the wall Hammer series
goes back into the well into the 1980s
40K specifically and so you have a you
have a Sci-Fi aesthetic rooted in that
era and so you wouldn't have any
Picatinny rails you wouldn't have little
sort of learned details like the the
magazine catch that also has a handy
shroud around it of that style that that
or that looks to be a lift from the FN
SCAR or a similar modern rifle it's on
the it's on the auto rifle it's on this
SMG as well so little details like that
where the I suppose they're sort of like
they're retcons very very minor rep guns
but um the original weapons from from
the first couple of Decades of this
franchise needless to say wouldn't have
had those features of modern Firearms
now they haven't gone they haven't gone
wild they haven't made this stuff look
like Call of Duty which is great point
is a lot of these things are going to be
designed to look cool and interesting
but then we do have these little hints
of the present day notably the picatinny
rail attachment system which isn't just
cosmetic of course it's it's part of the
gameplay and I'm absolutely certain that
I'm going to see some Optical sights as
well
oh
foreign
thrower flamer whatever you want to call
it incinerator unit definitely something
I associate with this universe it's hard
to give a flame projector presence
because it's not there's no working
parts there's no case ejection the the
muzzle flash is literally the the whole
event here that in itself is is pretty
impressive but importantly the way that
if the flame reaches a surface it sticks
and it burns that's the critical thing
the the big deal is this is thickened
fuel that you are squirting at high
pressure that happens to be on fire so
it doesn't just create heat damage and
then stop creating heat damage it
continues to burn and we see that to
great effect with the enemies two main
methods of use for this thing as well
and because of that burning effect kind
of want to spread share the love a bit
and um give short bursts to a number of
weaker enemies and then Focus your your
main burst of fire onto the onto the
bigger ones or something of that nature
well this appears to have automated
process so you've got the ability to
deliberately squirt a short burst and
then to give it the full blast when you
need to that might have a relevance in
terms of not the spool up time but
typically a game flame gun will take a
little while to start spraying that that
flank which is actually realistic that's
how it should work and so if it has an
automated short Dash version of its own
fire if that makes sense then you can
effectively do that whereas if you're
trying to like preempt and hold the fire
button and let it off to only get a
short burst that could could potentially
be frustrating so that's my take I think
they've tried to move things on a little
bit with the flamethrower this time I
thought I'd show you well a couple of
things this is the number five mark one
British flamethrower projector
um which is what the the what the Brits
called it it's the gun bit of the
flamethrower really all this is doing is
uh directing where the where the jet of
burning fuel goes the business end
really is the is the bit that's missing
we don't have the backpack for this
unfortunately now the other flamethrower
that I wanted to show you
is not a flamethrower
literally it says on the box we have the
box too and it says not a flamethrower
this was literally a weed burning gun
that you can buy in little housed in a
Sci-Fi airsoft gun casing you can even
see where the magazine would have gone
for the airsoft gun so it it kind of
looks the part as a pop culture sci-fi
flamethrower albeit it looks a bit too
clean and mass effecty for um for for
40K an interesting bit of
arms and armor culture that we thought
we should preserve even if it's not a
flamethrower
this thing is a lot of fun this is a
semi-automatic grenade launcher of some
kind that is
um I think it's described as a gauntlet
and it's that sort of fits in that it's
some of some of the receiver wraps
around the hand you can see this you
don't need me to tell you that which
allows it to be used and I guess where
the gauntlet part really comes in it's
it can be used by these massive dudes as
a melee weapon he's certainly firing it
with both hands when he's actually
firing it as a grenade launcher but then
when he goes to town with others people
it's just a one-handed weapon behaves I
would say and even sounds a lot like
something like an M32 any repeating
grenade launcher it has that that bloop
sound and that's somewhat realistic you
can see that it has an arcing trajectory
but it's quite flat so you're not having
to artificially compensate for the drop
effect on target is very much this has
to be in terms of high explosive even
then you don't it's got a bit too much
Hollywood Fireball if it were meant to
be a realistic thing it isn't so we want
final people there's a quite a cool
smoke after effect after the flame which
is realistic it did contain some kind of
incendiary capability like that you
would see some smoke come off it
all right so I'm on more familiar ground
with this thing because even I know
about bolt guns or bolters this has got
to be a little ditty one for for normal
human-sized people so I'm getting from
the information on the screen in fact
that uh you get automatic fire when hit
fired and semi-automatic when aimed of
course this thing doesn't have a bus
stop unless it's a modifiable to have
one and from memory I don't remember
bolt is even having one I guess the I
the idea with the Space Marine at least
in my head would be that he'd be able to
hold this thing Rock Solid steady
without having a butt stuff not the case
for ordinary people so but then if you
put a butt stuck on it it doesn't really
have the classic silhouette this is a
real the closest we've got so far to a
Bolter in terms of this idea of Rocket
ammunition it's very very basic it's a
die-cast metal body with a simple steel
tube set into that and a rear acting
hammer
that fires backward onto the nose of the
round it's not really a cartridge
because it's a self-contained round so
the nose doesn't actually do anything
but that that pushes it back onto the
primer because it does have a center
fire primer buried in here you won't be
able to see that then fires the Round
And Then There are four base exhaust
holes and that's the exhaust that
propels the round that it's not the
explosion inside that's that's pushing a
projectile it's launching itself it's
literally a miniature rocket so it
accelerates over the hammer recocking it
another round comes up behind it ready
for firing that the tube is just a guide
to get it on its way it's the rotational
stability of the rocket projectile that
keeps it stable fascinating area of
Technology this is a sort of Highly
stylized idealized version of it
[Music]
foreign
interest in the ammunition here looking
at the magazine we can see it's double
stack it's very large but then the
projectiles are very large and sound or
um Rockets missiles Munitions
effectively you can see that it has a
Centerfire primer something going on at
the front that we don't have on the
gyrojet round that is clearly whatever's
containing the payload that blows people
to shreds which is very impressive and
very cool so it's interesting this with
all my all my rambling about how this
would actually work in reality it's
almost like calling them Rockets is is
more like emphasis for their explosive
capability they're more like grenades
they're not really meaningfully rockets
in the way that the gyro jet is I don't
think you know they don't they don't fly
in in any way slowly they're not
accelerating from the muzzle like a
rocket would they're firing like a
miniature grenade round and they behave
like a miniature grenade ramp
78 the body dies
we move outside my area of expertise
with directed energy weapons especially
ones that are made up there's no
particular reason why an uh an energy
weapon a laser weapon would require to
look quite so much like a conventional
firearm with the magazine where the
magazine would normally be shaped much
like it would normally be the thing that
draws my attention is the sight I like
the fact that it's quite busy with
switches and dials and and what looks
like some conduit or something on the
right hand side it separates it a bit
from the generic Call of Duty modern day
Red Dot sight it's a little amusing that
it has the what's known as the Donut of
death uh reticle from the EOTech with
the circle with the four hash marks and
the dot in the middle hey if it works
keep it for forty thousand years but the
thing that's that's cool about this for
me is the gothic Arch slash church
window shape of the thing great way to
blend it in with with this world
his
name all right so this the impression
here is for me as a filthy casual
Warhammer person is a bit Gears of War
but then I know as soon as I say that
that Gears of War is the thing that owes
the debt to Warhammer and not the other
way around but uh yeah different design
aesthetic but absolutely fits with the
voltas design aesthetic caring less
about ergonomics chunky it's blocky it's
got screws or rivets all over it lots of
big easy to grasp controls stylized
pretty brutal looking bayonets not sure
if that's where Ripper comes from or if
it's because of how it burst fires so
the description's telling me it's going
to be burst and fully automatic and that
the bayonets functional so that's going
to be interesting
foreign
okay I'm a bit slow on the uptake with
this one but it it's clearly an
automatic shotgun the huge huge
cartridge case is coming flying out the
top of the gun the bolt thing it has a
functional bolt on top it reminds me of
and I forget which um which one it is
there's a a riot gun effect to be less
lethal Riot gum that somebody actually
posted online saying real life 40K
Bolter the way it works is very
reminiscent where you can see a lot of
the action as it opens up and it's a
slow chugging rate of fire that's
designed for right control this is I
guess potentially used for that but um
with the bayonets on the front probably
not it's just a short stubby very chunky
auto shotgun with a with a Bayonet on
the front bayonets on shotguns of course
rare but not unheard of the 1897 trench
gun had a bayonet as to how the bayonet
functions it's such a short gun that
he's just having to just push it out in
front of him bayonet fighting with model
fire arms is very much a elastic a
psychological weapon here it's a key
function of how the weapon works
all right first impressions this is
looking very familiar to me I don't know
if it's because I've seen it in
something Warhammer or if it just looks
like something else so the front half is
highly stylized very blocky very
Warhammer even the pump grip which you
can discern is bits that very well what
kind of gives it away fully as a shotgun
is the butt stock which is a a very
traditional semi-pistol grip shotgun
buttstop it does have a rib across the
top which is a feature of shotgun
barrels but here the rib extends all the
way across over the body as well
I'm reloading
down
in use then this thing is very shotgunny
pretty pretty conventional in terms of
its effect it's only so much you can do
with a with an FPS shotgun the way it
operates is is nice though what's
remarkable I think is the old alt fire
here where we're taking advantage of the
ability of a shotgun to five different
rounds it's very rare that games do
model that some of the more realistic
ones do that but for a Sci-Fi game
pretty interesting that they've
leveraged a real capability of a shotgun
and they have somewhat Justified the
existence of a manual pump on this thing
something that I I do occasionally
gringe about is why would you have a
pump action on a future shotgun when we
have self-loading shotguns already
they're making use of it here to let you
alt Fire by inserting the special round
now a lesser gain would would have you
just pull the trigger and you get that
secondary effect they are here having
the the player character manually cycle
that special round into the gun because
by loading it you've only loaded it you
haven't cycled into the chamber so if
you just pull the trigger you'd get that
ordinary shot first and then with the
self-loading ability then you'd get your
special shot the actual effect being
shown again is a real effect that the
spreading a shot at a certain height
that's achieved with well either a
highly specialized choke at the end of
the gun or an actual external duckbill
nozzle attachment it doesn't it can't
make it spread wider like this is it can
only constrain the top of the shot
pattern so a duckbill attachment
turns a pattern like this into a pattern
like this this gun turns a pattern like
say this into a pattern like this based
in a real thing exaggerated and made to
happen through ammunition which isn't a
thing and I'm not sure how it would be a
thing but answers on the usual virtual
postcard
IA
okay another last gun very reminiscent
of the ordinary one in the game but with
different barrel and oddly old-fashioned
looking wooden shotgun style but stuck
with a exaggerated metal butt plate so
the core system seems to be the same as
as what I've seen the other thing I
noticed is the gameplay ability to
charge up a shot with the little meters
there that would seem to tie in with the
massive Radiator on the barrel of this
thing which is very much like the old
1914 French Hotchkiss gun which if you
look up a picture of that has a gigantic
Radiator in approximately the same place
on the barrel possibly even an
inspiration for them I don't know if
this is a laser weapon you can charge up
that has to contain heat then a radiator
on the barrel makes sense makes it look
different now the bayonets and that
shotgun style buttstop give this thing a
real this this thing reminds you of the
1897 the Winchester 1897 trench gun from
the first World War or admittedly you
don't get the pump capability and it has
that green angular futuristic look that
a lot of the weapons in this game do but
it's sort of topped and tailed with
bayonet shotgun butt stock the overall
length is very reminiscent of that as
well
okay I think some credit deserved here
for making a video game revolver that
really looks different you can tell it's
a revolver from I guess the grip shape
And the cylinder but they've tried to
change up a lot of this thing so it's
not just yet another Magnum we've got a
bit of detail if there is a hammer there
are cylinder stop notches in the
cylinder which is how this thing works
although the trigger is not capable of
double action fire now based on the
description semi-automatic technically a
revolver cannot be well it can be before
people correct me in the comments but
the vast majority of revolvers are not
semi-automatic they just fire at one
shot per pull the trigger because you're
pulling the trigger all the way back
there isn't enough travel there isn't
enough trigger length here for this to
be anything other than single action but
needless to say I will I will let them
off something about that circular
trigger guard slash trigger housing and
the flatness of this frame is reminding
me of something I think I'm thinking of
and goodness knows if this is an
inspiration or not but given that a
version appeared in the Mandalorian
maybe the Bergman semi-automatic pistols
have that style of circular trigger
guard it's it's a it's a reach but
that's where my brain is going let's see
how this thing operates
in operation this this is reminding me
of big smooth cylinder very large rounds
only five fitting in the cylinder got to
be something like a Smith Wesson 500 but
it's honestly this is its own thing the
reload is there's some thought on into
it more thought than necessary frankly
for for a game of this nature break
action needless to say there's there's
an attempt to hold in the unfired rounds
with with the thumb which is not very
efficient but um would work and they've
bothered to to try which is which is
nice it has appears to have an ejector
star in the center of the cylinder that
doesn't get used and there's some kind
of a rod up front under the barrel that
I thought was going to come into play so
maybe the the user is just ignoring that
and using gravity uh the rear sight is a
bit curious it has two big adjustment
knobs on it for unknown purposes that
would that would tend to be for some
sort of elevation and windage adjustment
you wouldn't need both if it was just
one this clearly isn't a Target revolver
so I don't really know why those of that
whoa this thing is a bit left field
there are those conventional rounds
again which I'm not a fan of in Far Far
Future sci-fi I'm sorry belted linked
rounds this is a belt fed gun I'm not
seeing how those rounds get diverted
into what is apparently an upper and a
lower Barrel the barrels have very
chunky heat shields on them that bring
to mind a number of designs I suppose
the the Browning M2 is the the one
that's going to link leap to mind
especially as I this is called heavy
I've got no sense of scale but I think
given the rounds they're probably going
to be 50 cal or equivalent but they look
a lot like 50 BMG although from a
profile view you can only see the one
belt and I'm thinking yeah they fudged
it they're just diverting rounds up and
sun down no this is actually actually
reminiscent of a couple of our
anti-aircraft mounts that we have in the
collection here at the Royal armories
where you have well the one I'm thinking
of is four guns and you have shoots feed
shoots running from belt boxes side by
side at different heights into the
different guns basically exactly like
this because this is two guns that
happen to be screwed together by the
look of it operated off one trigger of
course they're offset they're displaced
for and aft but that makes sense because
the feed region of the gun has to align
with the belt so to actually offset the
top one to the rear does actually make
some sense so what looks looks like a
pretty wacky silly design actually for
somebody who has a tremendous amount of
strength is starting to make some sense
which is funny
foreign
fire modes here are pretty intriguing
actually it's akin to deploying a bipod
in a more realistic FPS so we're getting
a reduced dispersion when we flip out
the handle and Brace the thing more
deliberately and which which is logical
I have noticed uh something that
detracts somewhat from the realism as if
we care about the realism but the
cocking handle on the top yeah okay
that's that's accessible for the gun on
the top how are we cocking the gun on
the bottom I imagine it's a case of
there's a the cocking handle would go
straight through the bolt of the Top Gun
and be physically attached to the ball
to the bottom gun in a different
location and sheer brute strength means
you can [ __ ] them both from One charging
handle that's what I'm going with
is dead
all right this is very unusual of all
the guns we've we've looked at it's safe
to say this is the only one that is
based on a real gun this is a Warhammer
m79 now although the sight doesn't get
used this clamped on site Arrangement is
almost identical it's on the same place
on the barrel although I suppose that's
dictated by the site ladder the real
thing you press this catch and this
thing will is Deployable in the game it
just kind of sits there looking cool and
flapping up and down but yeah it's
remarkably similar from from here
forward almost identical it looks like
they've replaced some of the wood they
have studied an m79 to create this
weapon if we open it up
see but um the rifling in the barrel is
evident on the video game version as
well what can I say it's a it's a an m79
in space
all right guys I hope you enjoyed
our review of The Guns of Warhammer Dark
tide the more I see of that game the
more I want to play it as always we at
the Royal armories would love you to
come and visit one of our physical
museums if you can't we have our own
YouTube channel that you're very welcome
to come over and take a look at as well
not just me on there um there is a fair
bit of meat we've also got um social
media of course you can check out and
some events going on in the new year as
well
all right guys take care
[Music]